well so speaking of film so along the
roadside it's just now coming out is
that right yes okay coming now March
seventeenth MRSA oh well okay st.
Patrick's Day which is tomorrow or
amandas great okay that's sorry that's
where my mind went was st. Patty's Day
um so who gave you the script how did
you see it or did were you called um a
friend of mine by the name of Danny
Danny grow touch he's in the film he
plays mitts the cop and I saw him at a
party for was at an event and he's like
I'm in this movie you should be in this
movie too I think they're casting for
roles you should check it out and so he
connected me with the director Zorn and
then Zorn sent me the script and I read
the whole thing that night and I loved
it and I said to the director I said
listen I don't know who's playing the
lead and you probably have already cast
a body but I need to play this guy and
he was like all right well read for it
and at the time they did have someone in
mind for the lead they hadn't I don't
think they had officially cast him yet
but sent him audition tape I didn't want
to just do a tailor a filmed audition
and just read the scripts I wanted to
shoot my audition that way and then also
film it like an actual scene in the
movie so they can picture me in the role
you know I just wanted to take a step
further so you really have to hustle
then shortly after that day I got a call
him like you got the wrong I was like
yes yeah so yeah you play Barney I play
Barney okay and Barney's going through
some stuff yeah girlfriend barney is a
little bit on the run um you know he
kind of considers himself a sailor who's
left one shore but hasn't yet reached
the next so he's still kind of floating
and drifting and he's got a lot on his
mind you know cuz of some things that's
going on with him and his girlfriend and
that takes him pretty far or pushes him
pretty far i should say you know and to
his drift you know was this your first
lead in a dramatic film yes what yeah
definitely my first my first film first
leave did you feel you had to fight for
the audition or you just had to prove
that you were ready and well when you
know when you find out that they're
already considering someone for them for
their lead role and they've pretty much
kind of already cassidy yeah it's a
fight you know
but you know I'd like challenges I can
tell you like yeah so but you weren't
into sports no but you other than
fighting fighting Oh like emma Mae or
like martial arts yes ok when I was I
was in martial art and I was really
young so oh and now MMA is like that's
the only sport i watch so ok I don't
watch like football baseball basketball
no ah interesting what is it about that
challenge that I don't know I mean
because some people cower need to
challenge like that i don't know i'm
probably not explaining it right but
what is it where you just it seems like
you come alive when there's like steaks
on the line a little bit yeah i mean i
just think that's the mark of driven
people like we like challenges the
filling of accomplishment i'm filling
them full becoming something so yeah
yeah nice you are you ever satisfied
because that's another mark of
accomplished people's there never you
said earlier they always oh no I'm not
ever satisfied I'm not um and that's not
a bad thing it's just I just always want
more we're some people and friends and
family pat me on the back like oh that's
so amazing and i had i but i can do i
could be doing way more you know so
you